it's not frankly it's not something I'm
thinking about
um being an independent uh I am
continuing to do what I have been doing
which is to speak the truth and to call
it straight whether it's Democrats or
Republicans
um I think that there are obviously I've
been very clear in outlining the
problems that I've seen with today's
Democratic party if you look at today's
Republican party especially what's
playing out right now on c-spans I think
there's probably a lot of Republicans
who are asking well what is the
Republican Party stand for
when you're a guest on Tucker or now you
you fairly often guest host that that
alignment makes sense to you because
even though if you would have said five
years ago well wait a minute here's a
democratic congresswoman from Hawaii and
here's Tucker Carlson you know basically
in the Trump Camp let's say there's a
reason that it makes sense now because
so many people have woken up to all of
these infringements on our rights like
is that is that basically the Genesis of
what kind of brings these orbits
together
I think that's one of them
um I think that there are the more
people see and I think a lot of people
saw through the covid restrictions
people who maybe weren't even involved
politically or don't really pay much
attention to a lot of things or never
watched Tucker's show or maybe yours or
didn't pay attention to me or whatever I
think more and more people were like
well hold on a second
these decisions are causing uh my family
and my community to suffer my small
business to fail and so on but it
doesn't really make sense these are not
science-based decisions these aren't
decisions that are actually respecting
our civil liberties and freedoms and
really it just got to the heart of the
fact that we had people who got a little
bit of power and decided that they
weren't going to let it go and started
abusing that power and making decisions
that were more about themselves and
their power than it was actually about
helping people and so I think I think
there were
um and are
a a number of different contributing
factors that you see people uh who are
frustrated by
um Corporate America abusing their power
at the expense of working people you see
um
I I think you know you see uh
impingement on religious freedom in this
country and also policies this
Administration is putting forward uh in
different parts of the world so I think
there's a lot of different factors when
people look at well hold on what what
are the fundamental principles this
country was founded upon and are those
who took an oath to support and defend
the Constitution actually fulfilling
that oath and I think people are seeing
more and more that we have Democrats and
Republicans in power in this country who
care more for themselves than they do
for the people and that's where you see
a lot of folks from across the political
Spectrum I think coming together
putting aside the political labels and
just saying hey this this is not right
and this is not what this country and
our principles are all about
is that sort of what stops you from just
saying hey I'm a republican at this
point because you just feel like it's
just like an old game so what's the
point really because most of the things
that you're saying they do line up more
with Republicans I get Republicans
usually fail on those things but at
least it's the stuff that they talk
about which really the Democrats just
simply don't talk about anymore
it's not frankly it's not something I'm
thinking about
um being an independent uh I am
continuing to do what I have been doing
which is to speak the truth and to call
it straight whether it's Democrats or
Republicans I think that there are
obviously I've been very clear in
outlining the problems that I've seen
with today's Democratic party if you
look at today's Republican party
especially what's playing out right now
on C-Span
um I think there's probably a lot of
Republicans who are asking well what is
the Republican Party stand for and like
you said uh one example is on the issue
of civil liberties there are different
factions within the Republican party
people who might say yes we stand for
freedom and the Constitution and and
civil liberties but these are the very
same people who will stand up and defend
all of the egregious uh Provisions
within the Patriot Act that undermine
our civil liberties
um we see the the you the pro war
machine uniparty in Washington lead
leaders in both political parties
I will say there is a glimmer of hope on
the Republican Party side because unlike
the Democratic party where there
apparently are no voices now saying well
hold on we should exercise restraint we
shouldn't be going and trying to get
ourselves into new cold Wars and nuclear
armed races and nuclear war with other
countries at least on the Republican
side there's a small but growing number
of of elected leaders in Congress who
are who have the courage to stand up
against the military-industrial complex
in the war machine in Washington and
their own leaders in their own party
saying this is not good for the American
people this is not good for our country
so you know I I think I think it's it's
most important for us
to look to
holding leaders accountable from both
political parties and actually try to
bring about that that systemic change
that brings us back to uh the
Constitution not just in words but in
reality and also brings us back to what
I think is the most important premise
that our leaders should use in making
these decisions whether on domestic or
foreign policy is what is in the best
interest of the American people what is
in the best interest of ensuring the
safety security and freedom of the
American people in this country are you
worried that just too many people don't
believe that that could happen so you
know if you were to look at the 1.7
trillion dollar spending Bill and we're
going to defend the borders of Oman and
Jordan but not our own borders that at
this point there's been a certain black
pilling at least at the federal level
where people are just like it just does
not work period as I say on my show all
the time I live in Florida where
everything is highly functional and
competent and decent so I have a very
weird disconnect between my data day
life and sometimes the things that I'm
talking about on the show because here
it's freaking working maybe we can
export some of that but I think a lot of
people feel they look at a bill like
that they look at the amount of people
well I guess I'll ask it to you this way
would you have voted for that freaking
thing I would not no I would not have
voted for it there is no question in my
mind for a whole host of reasons but
that bill is is
I think it's right that that bill and
all that it represents
um is something that is at the heart of
this whole debate around who the next
house speaker will be I think some of
the problems are that we're seeing play
out is that
um
I I don't know that the you know again
I'm not in those rooms at all I'm not
privy to private conversations at all
that are going on there but what is
being reported it doesn't seem like the
the peripheral changes that are that
they're talking about in those
negotiations are getting to kind of what
the heart of of the problem is and so
you know we'll see how that all shakes
out but I think that some of the issues
raised by people like Congressman chip
Roy are important and those are not uh
necessarily issues that are owned by
quote unquote conservatives or
Republicans I think there's a lot of
people in the country who just look at
this from a common sense perspective and
say well no it doesn't make sense for
you know Congress to pass this 1.7
trillion dollar bill that very few most
I would say didn't take the time to read
and look at and actually I'm pretty sure
we can say zero you saw you've signed a
couple of these type of things right
like this thing right plus plus you get
what barely barely 72 hours like not
even working hours like 72 uh I guess
clock hours before you actually have to
vote on this thing and oh by the way
there's no open Amendment so you can't
you know as a member of Congress I would
not have been able to go in there and
say I have problems with these and these
and these provisions and then offer an
amendment on the house floor uh they
stopped allowing that a long time ago
um there's no actual open opportunity to
debate what is in the bill so it just
goes to just how broken how broken the
process is
um I think you started the question by
asking you know
is it too far gone basically right it
can't can it be fixed I think as messy
as it is what we're seeing happen play
out now with this house Speaker question
um is the kind of thing that needs to
happen in order to start bringing about
the changes that actually fix what's
wrong yeah and just for the record we're
taping this on Friday afternoon I think
they're in their 12th round right now
and a few people did switch to McCarthy
but we're posting this on Monday so Lord
Only Knows what'll happen if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell